hey hey hey
what is up guys my name is
and yeah today we're going to celebrate
because i got 100 subscribers oh my god
100 subscribers
okay i shouldn't do sound effects but
anyway
to a lot of people 100 subscribers is
probably an instagram insignificant
number but to me to me it means a lot so
i just want to thank you guys so much um
like for all your support it doesn't
matter if you're
i don't know a new subscriber or been
here i don't know how long i've been
doing this one and a half months maybe
um
i just want to thank you guys i love you
all equally
uh thank you so much for commenting on
my videos and rating them and
subscribing and participating in any way
it just makes me happy
um so yeah this is my thank you to you
i'm not gonna comment on the
on the gameplay because i [ __ ] hate
way to matches and
i don't know why i ever bothered playing
it
every time i get knifed in the gun game
or
get tomahawk in uh
what the [ __ ] is called sticks and
stones i seriously want to take my diary
and smother it on the screen with my
hands
i wouldn't i would wear gloves though
because it's kind of disgusting to have
[ __ ] on your hands okay i should change
subjects that was that was even more
disgusting but anyway uh
thank you guys so much and uh some of
you have been asking me uh
okay so you do commentators commentating
and um
like what's the net next thing do you
want to be on machinima do you want to
be famous okay i guess i guess it's a
little early to talk about those kind of
stuff but i just want to address uh this
and say that
uh no no i don't wanna i don't wanna be
famous uh
but sure i i can be on machinima like
why not i think it's a good goal for me
to aim for um
i like to aim at even at big goals even
though they might not be relevant at all
but
uh also what kind of what i meant to say
is that i crave for very little
attention and i don't do this because i
want to be famous that's the
main thing i wanted to say uh the only
reason why i do this is because it's fun
and you guys are the biggest part of
that like it's because of you guys that
this actually is fun and that's why i
make videos and that's why i'm going to
keep making videos so thank you guys
again so much
uh
also i want to say uh
uh what was it oh yeah um in every video
i tried to remember to say that you're
awesome for watching and uh which you
are of course uh but this time i wanted
to make you feel awesome
not in a sexual way or anything yeah
peter that's growth
uh i know but
that's not what i meant i
in i'm gonna leave two links in
description and open them and just
get your favorite drink or whatever and
just feel awesome because you deserve it
and
other than that that was pretty much it
i that was all i had to say i guess i'll
talk to you guys tomorrow